[Música]
Esta es Martinica una isla francesa del
Caribe donde las plantaciones de plátano
y azúcar se extienden hasta donde
alcanza la vista a pesar de ello
Martinica depende en gran medida de la
importación de alimentos en este
supermercado El 80% de los productos no
se producen en la isla pan de Canadá
miel de moldavia como los productos
vienen de muy lejos suelen costar un 10%
más que en la Francia continental antes
vivía en la Francia continental y ahora
me he trasladado aquí las diferencias de
precios Son escandalosas a veces vemos
una diferencia de precio de 5 6 o
incluso 10 euros el queso rallado
costaba unos 5 euros el kilo
aproximadamente así que ronda Entre 10 y
11 euros en ciertos sitios realmente es
increíble para tratar de reducir las
importaciones de alimentos los isleños
se han orientado hacia el cultivo local
de sus productos estas pequeñas
plantaciones no podrían ser más
diferentes que los monocultivos de
plátanos y azúcar que cubren gran parte
de las tierras de Martinica sin embargo
este agricultura ecológico sigue
teniendo que importar algunas de sus
semillas esta rúcula viene de Italia en
Martinica carecemos de producción
alimentaria en cuanto a verduras de hoja
verde el objetivo aquí es aumentar
nuestra producción para garantizar
nuestra soberanía alimentaria el clima
de Martinica es ideal para los cultivos
de Jonathan cultivó una gran variedad de
verduras que acaban en las estanterías
de los supermercados locales esta
diversidad de cultivos ayuda a regenerar
el suelo que ha quedado desprovisto de
nutrientes tras años de agricultura
intensiva el hecho de que tengamos más
diversidad en términos de producción de
alimentos garantizar la seguridad
alimentaria para el futuro y lo que es
más importante satisfacer las
necesidades de nuestra Isla los
cacautales solían predominar en la isla
pero han sido sustituidos por otras
plantaciones este agricultor espera
invertir la tendencia y ha plantado
cacaoteros en las tierras de su familia
los árboles de aquí se plantaron hace
menos 10 años y ya van por su tercera
cosecha esperabas esto Bueno me lo
esperaba pero Igualmente me sorprendió
Luciana y unos cuarenta productores más
en su mayoría pequeñas empresas trabajan
con una asociación local especializada
en la producción sostenible de cacao
fuimos a observar sus técnicas en otros
países del Caribe ya que allí nunca han
dejado de producir
vimos como fermentan
y hoy poco a poco estamos reaprendiendo
todos los métodos
Aunque la producción de cacao en la isla
sigue siendo limitada la asociación
espera poder triplicarla en los próximos
cinco años apostando por reavivar el
amor europeo del siglo XVII por el que
acabo de Martinica si la posibilita esto
permite a los chocolateros franceses
decir hoy tenemos la posibilidad de
hacer chocolate 100% Francés
pero el renacimiento de los productos
locales no se limita al Wow esta fábrica
de jugos de frutas quiere aumentar su
cuota de Mercado en la isla aquí se
producen unas 30 toneladas de jugo al
día su directora afirma que estas
máquinas podrían producir el doble si
hubiera demanda aquí tenemos máquinas
demasiado eficientes y rápidas en
comparación con el mercado para el que
trabajamos y las 300.000 personas que
viven en esta Isla
para aumentar la demanda la marca
acentúa sus credenciales locales con una
pegatina martinic en sus botellas su
forma de diferenciarse de los
competidores europeos
ayuda instantáneamente al cliente a
tomar una decisión y asegurarse de que
compra sistemáticamente productos con
esa etiqueta
esta certificación sostiene miles de
puestos de trabajo en la isla desde
productores industriales hasta pequeños
artesanos con la población de Martinica
mayoritariamente a favor de una mayor
autosuficiencia alimentaria los vientos
de cambio parecen soplar en la dirección
correcta